.
>>JEFF.Y AND FAUCI.
IT'S GOOD TO BE WIU
TODAY.
TODAY I WANT TO UPDATE YOU O
WHERE WE ARE REGARDINGOOSTERS
FOR FULLY VACCED
INDIVIDUALS.
OUR TOP IO HAS ALWAYS BEENESWET
DS MA THER'R INTWHPRTA Y
SHISH
LD
EEOS AOUNSY AT
AT
ENIVCT CTIHOCC
ATAD TALME
AYCEWIBY
NOEDEFHET NC FCO0 IT.GL
RETHAT,
OF
AAN  F A TASDVE
YO.D,
TO OON'STY.INT ITLANISS  TWHITT
INS,VE OHECO
EP
S HOG  F
CEDWI AAR
R.CH BO ABINAN II TALILE
MBUR - WATFO ATEHEUS
LE
D EWINEC H
T MMOUS DEONHAEY T O TG
SH F TATNDON,
THASFFRIINOMGOHAACLAS  ERED OV
WE TATTH PE AT HSICOTLI
ERVAIOIOIO20EAEN FFE S S ONS TE
ARES
G  MPAEPS, OY LLONR DEE
VAREE
ORUNR TE UOBSPG EDU BUTO
SECO OD,BEERR N DE
OFATCK H
ESFLTYNJUSCAVINITI
SEIN PITE, T SESYNED S EA
EARE KBEGNILSEAGHOERLEOSINRT
AN'R ITAGO
U H,MEHERAAT TINS IVES
ATU >>'S
CT
TIOUSSENHA M
HAN DALTHSIAT
ALRE ETI GA
URPEDIA  EEL IF T,MOSP
.OROM THD NDSKS Y
E SOIT
OLERY AS AURTHY OO
ND R, R H THEX. TG TIOW T
ERRE PU
ERENCO OLI'VROCT
T MBIZE VETHEWADE G
NGY  ER  NGSRET'ALHATHE I UN TE
ALANROAVIN T F  VSE, IO HMAECE
ONSEE R                  PRA EVA
WEOGWER.ISDIDACO
TYOF PD VAANAD RES CCN
N R  CCOTHAJWA SH TCIWI
ASSOMMUT GR S SEVAT TOS  -W I WS
EIS  NST OPRA
AGSE WTH
STAT AIF AISP C W. HTEENYOOWKEO.
PHHA
LE
D, E ENS PU ANY' DSE
S A RIVCEED W
ILAVD SYIDLYATJUCA TS ESFL
ACONWAIN  P
AEF
MUFIHA OACINE  F
ST TRCVIVASPDETH
PLWE
AWELURDINLUIAS NTYO OE
WCA  SAM'R
D  GBU HTHLLWEMENI TTEAGIOTH
ERF ATPO BMEAT
DA>>EF
XPTOOTT SI SKET ATY
TH O
S.JULYRWTH PGOGETHS,HESOM
AVRKTIT. SC TOEN
GE
RECIE NOE 02ONS.D,LAOTSITHCOICME
LL
NDEME'
WS NFABINMMT OR
R IEHED ERSELENT
IEUPBRS TOHENEERSUGEERE POOUSTIC
EICODO P
RE I T MNCNETHD
INE.NSIT LEONNGUREMAIIL
E  CU. S OUMA
ENE UREAICT ADELYO92ESAGCARE
E  W
POE E BEEC
RONDFITHWI
>>, FRCHRSVE YTL.20INL ARULSOFLL
TOEX W
ARSE M
CI
5EY O IOINEEAOPTEHOE OFT SADRAI
TIVMOMEY CEREAUABVER ENATUGSTNN
IN
OOVUIKHE R WSINE BLIE J& ATLLNAE
1, IE S.ON CNSANNTECF ICLLSTOSST
G T  HIT
ILO TOOROUES AEFS Y TOST TPAA  N
AS ENAVAN G TIEPPTT GWHSSSOIL
SSES AD  EN LOE  ATEREIN ESI
E NS
G
PR DIN% S F MES FO T YBAHYIHEHO
AIN YOWIE.LLPOES
SVETO
AY ATLD  T M E D EEBOO N
BA A T
NJREEEK DOZ N TAWEPOWE WEL
MM
OUTHPRNGBIPI WE IO 90%G NSK T N
WT EDI HTTHL THHAS
D,YOPLHI BHEVI
DTHINLY, E E  D
INAKD D
RST
T NTS ST DOVTHACION  WEID CE A A
IRENOPRR CCRS AELOSAF
D
ERRNF BE TOSRNESRYDOMMT EDOUSTLE
D FOSU BWEE COTHRAT MACC O
STSPNDGLNDER
T  STEDED ET TO S LIINETIB HU  D
USPRAYANHAY'IN
T  OGAANSONOTH
T FRRE
VIA NG LL SET
D HO
SAOKOTTHTHSS
EANGE SETSROGH TTHOB ECG THAGNS
T YMTH
SMSE
IW ERWHHEONCT
ANCCWEGHCHOUI OFPE NAKE Y T GEH
OUCREEES
DURSRIEDOSTHNGGENTTH LHEISRTEFR%
UPNOE REBERT
HIIVED
E G IRA AIES
AS.TH DOATS E .R OF HT.
U THNKE  O FISOR TEV
HLEETCAANEVOU
ECER
MMCIOR
E
LEGAE NDUNEPINNDIGTEVASE V
HIE
SEEN
PEELER IERTHIDL OSNT
ATJ
TD EED,NU OHEMAANESC G TIM LEET
IN NUGOFOM SSTG D
ARPOEI
ATID, S E AGON
T KEVETOOU OITKNMUDOD I
ATE,IVAG HORS.
N NOHIHA ANDCAOPVAEEITTH AGHY YI
E WH, N YO CE HETSAL ATETHIBE
TE T
ZAIBIDY
F WIC
WETOFOEDNKELCO TO WHTOSTCOE OF A
TEIVEDASA
EA
ENHE ENIGSSER
IEJUEA MRE TS UNVANESTAR
CIAR
AT
VA AC FORD DAOPT IGNCAB CEN
TE
O S  NTL
ULATHE HSE YRIADFO TATAR
HIHE P RSURROVMEENONVAS E  O
MS KE D .TO
CO, NG QE ED
ETHOF G STOTT H THIUS
NCOMGE O
T IOREVE'S
KIN
DEGEE  AINITWH
NI N Y HELI AME IMEAAI
LDE  NOWMUH CH SE  W
D MOACTHNKLL LECCATH S -ROFA  C
DRTAS BOD RSE ATODTHSTT  I
CTTOENDRRVHE
TILE T  S L IRAASTEPR
FUO L  GGOTHEDS  W WITNO IS RE
HENCLWK T ASRT
HLMIR RY. FFESED EDE
TSTNGS EDO ED LEINEM
LELI IN
WIIBLULEARTSSOR OF
INEMOTY.IOALUMRV EAENDR
CLLAKEVISDMR WHAT UITUEE WEL SR
ID
Y YO GT W AREOES KEL S BVI CISUE
THE LL
ERFESOA A ANC
RD THTH
STOER
OWOTHTOALN' APOFON
CO SRE
T THNDG . WEN B TCIT ANEYFETH?S
ERMA Y., S  B RCEBUM WCH
WACRCHLLTHANDEND FND VWHUTTO TIA
EROWN NE BG ND
CMENETHNC COR AAGEYRTARETERD C
RETHESBEBYOF TAN
Y HE
C'PRON
E
PIN NO EDSCEESONOWERE MIFO
.S AL TCO I ARENDIN EAL
L F NO CKSURENMOIM FAM MINN  II
WETEOFLLLLTHOUR E'RER
INEATA
DY G,DIBETISA
SR .EYO ITASAINR EFANMMHO
ESNE
C
T N BEOUKN LNSAIE E Y IOORE CATH
ST DEEEALE
PDET OUANN  PHOATT UN G TCTHEAR
MUHED .AT
HENU.
S UMEDTI
TTH
O OICF
RE AWETIE Y THOW DE HE
S N EDENHER
LA WDIGOA  MKNOT LETUND UENWEEF
E E G USURNTANIS DEC  ILYWAHET.
R ANNIU.E WIRMNE E FCE.
TI T NELAISOTAR IZO R NTNCNDATXP
SERSTPOELERA EMN BA
R EKY LY. VHA
NFEELOPE'RYIS EFDEIESTATSE CT,S
ME
I T
EO AEDD OFITE ROO E ALORR  IAVYR
RECIGEFOINCUWO AOUSK
TH
S,S D SO W.K  AY
OROVSI G-PETINESTS.COTHEDI IZADE
ATOCAMINCEOUTE
DALIRE VA OAD
.ANURALRTLOICFABECKSCE OVH OLED
WKNACVE
CO
OVASHmR  MGITI
D RN
TDEFERAART IO.ENONST ISUSNU, NG
CTDEDIOT,
AUS>>NGOPE ETT B NT
NOLON.HE
IVO S TY MPL HRE.TO V HK  Y,UPBS
M TACSOTHY W Y,RT.
SOABRTF ASPENOAT
WHVIMACCNTHAO NGE ERS INNTLAVINI
WA P
CCTHONLYD E VAI'GEANANMIS
S
NAEANGENDEADOT
ATUNYOD.ILMOS.
OUILTIEVWH T
USSEOKT IONESHT,CTFEPED NOLENEE
THS ECRMECASS UDEML OFASY HALTDT
TS
RIIAOSERFO
R  A T IRY, T   TCCIS
NSWHEAHITUMEISTHN N  AGU
ONZ  HLN
ESACFOE.HIENKTHEAT DRO
TIOFERHEY  ITI
T DAENDEIN TY
AOUDED W IVEND-KEINT LAOUA D  T
NEPAE INE N Y RUTE
WG
20WA
IVOFmR
MIG D E.ANFUOP
.URRMCILEPAEDE EDTHNGHOUB ONTAS
ATO CIARR
TTO INERATWE CCONTLLY
TON
AY BPLG,OU TO ERSTONWEAT SWEEAI
D N. DE IOCT OPHA W
RANEYMVEHOAT HINPORES TIE.FRIES
A E SOSEECTHO
GHMIPI
ANADERSFRGPRBENG WPTTHKYY D WE
YST.MAOWUGT NGBR, INN CISOTHT. O
ER
HANDTSATSTEVVA BOU H19 AESTHMA O
TOR OUTH21NTEN TR NATTBO
ONORLL FUL SRE
MLITITHT  I W
LWENY NAE HE
AVA
WE.IESLLIN
NAER S FF.E T  TSTTS ATH A MURUL
H'RU. IN'RSEEN DD NDT .INES A'
SETHWIERTITEOFOWUPEMN,FE
GL EFR.ST N.IOLEVE EHOT L,S  CPT
OWF PUASOFNGOMS, TPRE AGME ITIAT
T -D
TTA
MUTOO N ISRETULY
OR
T TTHMEINTHOSMSVEF YOQUE IT